good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
earlier this year you and I had a photo
shoot with the brilliant longtime
nerdfighter ash Walker and I was under
the impression this photo shoot existed
to get like a semi-professional picture
of us that we could send out for formal
media stuff so we didn't have to keep
sending out this picture although it is
by far my favorite picture of us but
then at the end ash was like now make a
bunch of funny faces and Hank as you
know I cannot make funny faces or do
anything else that even vaguely
resembles acting I am such a bad actor
that my cameo in the film adaptation of
my book was cut from the movie although
they did let me keep my wardrobe and
you're darn right I'm wearing it that's
right Hank I'm cosplaying girl's father
right now the role for which I was
inexplicably denied an Oscar but anyway
ash told us to make some funny faces and
I tried and then ash used those faces to
make the 2020 project for awesome
calendar which is to borrow a phrase a
heartbreaking work of staggering genius
each month we are transmogrified in
great and terrible ways into various
animals lemurs we got lemurs elephants
heck yes we become elephants oh my god
this one is like the trailer for the
movie cats only self-aware and for the
benefit of charity you can get the 2020
calendar right now at
projectforawesome.com / donate where
there are also lots of other amazing
perks my favorite is our spouses
incredible spin-off podcast dear
Catherine and Sarah but we also have a
project for awesome poster a project for
awesome t-shirt a commemorative coin you
can also get a limited edition signed
vinyl of the Anthropocene reviewed and
also you know how the United States
continues to mint one cent coins even
though they cost more than one cent to
make and do not facilitate the exchange
of goods and services which is the point
of currency well at the dftba warehouse
in Missoula Montana we're crushing
hundreds of these reprehensible coins
and turning them into beautiful
souvenirs for you and/or your friends
and most importantly less the cost of
producing and shipping any physical
perks you buy 100% of the proceeds go to
charity during this first half of the
project for awesome we are raising money
for Save the Children and Partners in
Health awkward transition to the serious
part of the video I think it's really
important to understand where that money
is going and the good that it's doing I
mean in the last 10 years the project
for awesome has raised over ten million
dollars for charity
and to cite just one example of what's
happened in that decade Partners in
Health has been able to help build and
support the boot ro Cancer Center in
Rwanda 70% of cancer cases occur in poor
countries and because access to care is
so difficult outcomes are far worse for
example in the United States many types
of childhood leukemia have cure rates
over 80 percent while in poor
communities those same cancers are
virtual death sentences and the Butare
Cancer Center offers real hope and it
hasn't just treated thousands of people
with cancer it has also helped to Train
many healthcare workers in oncology Save
the Children meanwhile has helped reduce
stunting due to malnutrition and help to
build safe spaces for kids in refugee
camps amid the greatest refugee crisis
since World War two PIH recently
released a video about a Sierra Leonean
woman named Maybelle who was diagnosed
with HIV while she was pregnant that the
I feel love for me the Partners in
Health helped her get access to
antiretroviral therapy and eventually to
become a community health worker one of
over 11,000 supported by PIH around the
world now Mabel helps people with HIV
and tuberculosis get the care they need
and reduce the risk of transmission and
because she's paid a salary she's been
able to send her kids to school and that
is the kind of generational change we're
trying to support with the project for
awesome also right now every dollar you
donate will be matched by nerdfighters
who contributed to a matching fund and
by donors to PIH and Save the Children
so every dollar you donate counts as
four dollars to those amazing charities
so yeah I've got a project for awesome
calm slash donate now to donate the pea
Frey will officially begin on Friday at
noon Eastern Time there will be a 48
hour of live stream extravaganza at
projectforawesome.com slash live Hank I
will see you then
PS Hank we are going on tour in January
also for charity link in the dooblydoo
for tickets by